define a dilation that maps line a onto
line b by choosing a center and a scale
factor so let me get my scratch pad out
to think about this a little bit
so let's just for just for fun
let's imagine that we pick a point
let's imagine that we pick a point that
sits on line a as our center of dilation
and for simplicity let's pick the origin
so let's imagine that our center of
dilation is at zero comma zero and let's
just pick an arbitrary scale factor
let's say our scale factor is 2 and
let's think about what happens
this means that each of the points on
point a are going to get twice as far
from our center of dilation after the
dilation than they were before the
dilation twice as far so for example
point this point right over here it's
three away in the x direction before
dilation so it's going to be six away in
the x direction after dilation
likewise it's three away in the y
direction before dilation so it's going
to be twice as far in the y direction
after dilation so it's going to go from
the point 3 3 to the point 6 6. notice
it got twice
twice as far away from the center of
dilation
dilation essentially got pushed out
along the line
same thing for this point this point is
three less than the wider three less
than the x direction than our center and
three less than the y direction than our
center so after a scaling after a
dilation centered at the origin with a
scale factor of 2 is going to be twice
as far away so it's going to be 6 less
than the x direction and 6 less than the
y direction once again just pushed out
so notice when we picked a center of
dilation that sits on the line it really
doesn't matter what scale factor we pick
we'll just essentially be stretching and
shrinking the points along the same line
and since this line just keeps going on
and on and on forever in both directions
it's really just going to map onto
itself if this was a line segment we
would be mapping it to a different line
segment that would have the same slope
but its length would change but a line
has an infinite length so as you stretch
and squeeze it it still has an infinite
length and it's just mapping it on to
itself so this dilation right over here
a
is going to map onto itself it's just
going to map onto a
so that's not going to suit our purposes
but what can suit our purpose is if we
pick another point that's not on a and
not on b so let's say we pick
let's say we pick this point right over
here and i like
i like this point and so let me pick
that as my center i'll tell you why i
like it in a second that is the point
three comma two
three
comma two the reason why i like that
is we can see that this point on point a
right now is one away
and i want if i want to map it to the
corresponding point on point b
well that's going to be
that's going to be three away from our
center of dilation so i could have a
scale factor of three if i have a scale
factor of three it's going to go three
times as far away
scale factor
of
3. and that'll work for other points as
well for example this point right over
here it's 1 to the left of our center of
dilation if we have a scale factor of 3
it's going to be 3 to the left so it's
going to map if we think of it that way
you could think of it as going as going
right over there so i'm going to go with
center 3 2 scale factor of 3 and you
could have picked many many other in
fact an infinite number of other centers
and then you would have to calculate the
appropriate scale factor for each of
those but i like this one because it
fit nicely on the grid and i was able to
figure out how much to scale it so let
me so i picked my center so i want to
dilate i want to pick my center
at 3
comma
2 and i want to scale it by 3. so let's
check our answer
got it right